hello welcome to PlayStation granade
cheating and piracy have plagued video
games for decades don't get me wrong
some cheat codes give extra life to
video games like infinite bullet time in
Max Payne or DK mode in the old James
Bond game but gaining an unfair
advantage are completely ripping off a
game developer to play for free is an
offense which deserves punishment I'm
not talking about court cases or boring
legal jargon this list is 11 times video
game pirates and cheats were ashamed and
humiliated by the devs what would you do
if you were freed I'd go after the
Kingslayer 2011's The Witcher 2
assassins of kings was estimated to have
been pirated over 4 million times
leaving a huge hole in CD Projekt Reds
revenue for the game instead of
introducing DRM to control the use of
the software project red decided to do
something a little bit more terrifying
as you know The Witcher is filled with
beautiful ladies - mm-hmm impress and
make out with of course completely for
finding your soul mate well should you
play a pirated version of The Witcher 2
all those beautiful females become
Haggard old ladies what the heck is that
making the scenes of love a little
difficult to watch especially after a
meal unless you're into that kind of
thing of course and Who am I to put you
down let's let's move on from granny
love I love narcissism my wife a
challenge
but there's a limit here GTA online
revolutionized how Rockstar made games
and made ridiculous amounts of cash
people spend their real money or earn
in-game cash to purchase upgrades buying
highly desired vehicles with improved
armor and horsepower keeps the players
grinding and coming back every day well
back in 2015
cheaters found a way to bring a vehicle
from the single-player game into the
online world this isn't just any vehicle
this beast is the dukkha death the
two-door armor muscle car was completely
overpowered in GTA online allowing
players to grief others in the lobby and
generally being unpleasant to everyone
as this pandemic spread Rockstar
blacklisted the car but didn't patch the
method to bring the Jukka death into the
online game but the moment that vehicle
was used it would immediately set ablaze
and explode the griefers became the
griefed in 2017 the Jukka death was
legitimately added to the online portion
of the game but it was rebalanced to fit
better within the world
h1z1 the og Battle Royale title made it
over to ps4 recently but it's being
around seemingly forever over on the PC
a few years back the developers banned
30,000 cheaters who hacked themselves
into godlike beings who could clip
through walls one-shot opponents and
ruin the game for legit players here's
the brilliance of h1z1 approach they
offered redemption to get back on the
game those dirty cheats had to upload an
apology to YouTube which was then
tweeted out by the developers to spread
their shame those players who spent
hundreds of dollars on in-game items
took up this option in witty remorseful
comedic and downright emotional ways in
my life fo you that I will never cheat
again in this game was such a fool to do
it in the past and I sure will never
make that mistake again
most of the video she had a notion that
if they couldn't beat the cheaters
they'd join them but thankfully this
approach scared away a huge amount of
cheats and to restore the true colors of
those who genuinely wanted redemption
for their actions I genuinely am sorry I
didn't think anything would happen by me
just hacking once well you were wrong
sorry you're very wrong
[Music]
or friend the long time
speaking of redemption Red Dead
Redemption the Wild West inspired action
adventure and online shenanigan fest had
its own problems with cheaters back in
2010 instead of opting to ban these
users their approach was to utilize the
law and order from within the game my
name's John Marston throughout the
entire campaign and online to the
cheaters were constantly pursued by the
sheriff's that would never ever go away
maiming the experience torturing the
players and ripping the fun out of the
game
cheaters be want of all the things I've
seen on the battlefields of the frontier
but pilot is the true dominant force
titanfall and Max Payne 3 used a similar
way to Merc those cheats and pirates as
aimbots and wall hacks became prevalent
both developers decided to put all
cheats in the same server keeping the
real competitive lobbies free from dirty
cheats and most amusing forcing all
cheaters to understand how unpleasant it
is to face hackers and cheats
this is a moment in life where you will
look back one day and say I made a stand
or I did nothing one of the most
renowned examples of hacking was in an
MMORPG Guild Wars 2 beginning life in
2012 the game grew rapidly almost as
quickly as the game rose in popularity
the exploits of one player Darkseid
also became word of legend Darkseid was
regularly reported for exploiting hacks
in the game some gave him teleportation
powers others made him incredibly strong
and another gave him the ability to
instantly revived if he were to fall in
battle eventually the developers got
wind of the atrocities and decided to
publicly ban the cheater their first
step was to hack into his account
step 2 involved removing all his items
and stripping him down to his boxer
shorts next he was forced to climb to
the top of a tower and flung his
character to death even giving a wave
before his final moment immediately
after this the player was banned for
life but the tale of cheating and the
consequences of cheating in Guild Wars 2
shall forever go down in history
[Music]
anti-piracy Protection evolved and the
new approach was made by the developers
of Serious Sam 3 for those that don't
know Serious Sam is a first-person
shooter with blistering pace and
frustratingly difficult enemies this was
made even harder for cheaters with the
introduction of this guy
the blood-red scorpion is immortal and
can attack the player anywhere in the
game skating across the ground it's
impossible to escape and you will die
multiple times it was essentially
serious Sam's version of the nemesis
from Resident Evil but he legitimately
cannot be defeated those cheetahs got
used to seeing that game over screen
when Paul came back he took away the
only person who could start the end of
time
my brother will over on the Xbox quantum
break was released in early 2016 it's a
sci-fi action shooter with a few puzzle
elements thrown in
of course those cheaters found a way to
pirate the game but this time the
developers didn't make the game
unplayable - pirates they instead
attempted to target players who wanted
to stream or post YouTube videos subtly
the main character would wear a new
piece of headgear to symbolize their
pirated copy of the game none other than
a pirate's eye patch complete with skull
and cross swords this follows on from
remedies similar shaming to Lynn Alan
Wake those youtubers who uploaded videos
with the eyepatch would instantly shame
themselves and their audience would
probably disown them mobile gaming isn't
let off the hook as many handheld games
have included devilish ways to troll
cheaters and pirates over on the
Nintendo DS version of Michael Jackson
the experience you may be playing the
game to experience the brilliance of
MJ's music but instead you'll be hearing
this
the dulcet tones of the vuvuzela in an
interview a Ubisoft representative
revealed their unique ways to punish
pirates by obscuring audio with the
sound of the most annoying instrument in
the world
the bloody vuvuzela some people would
say that improves MJ's music I'm not one
of those people I quite like it
another devilishly clever way to
dethrone cheat Kings was seen in
operation flashpoint the cheaters
wouldn't even know it was happening
but over time their weapons would
respond a little differently
first the accuracy of their weapons
would reduce over time and then the
damage output would slowly lower to
making them ultimately cannon fodder and
unable to progress in the game genius
humiliation and finally let's look at
the winged vigilante in Batman Arkham
Asylum welcome to the madhouse Batman
this punishment was extremely sneaky and
first allowed the cheaters to play as
normal enjoying the combat and other
elements of the game that was until they
came across a room filled with gas
usually the only way to get across is to
use the iconic gadgets at Pat man's
disposal in particular the bat cape to
glide above the poisonous gas but here's
where the cheaters became stuck the bat
cave wouldn't work in a pirated version
of Arkham Asylum making the game
impossible to complete this became even
more amusing as players attempted to
make impossible jumps to reach the other
side and when they finally gave up and
asked the internet for help they were
met with this response the problem you
have encountered is a hook in the
copy-protection to catch up people who
try and download cracked versions of the
game for free it's not a bug in the
game's code it's a bug in your moral
code ouch that has to hurt your pride so
that was it there's 11 ways devious devs
shamed and humiliated cheats and pirates
what did I miss do you know any other
examples of punishment in video games I
would love to know them I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been an
absolute pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]